okay i think we should get started
uh so thank you everyone for joining us
for the very last
session of this workshop it's been a lot
of fun so far
and uh i'd like to invite
uh or i'd like to introduce michael
whitman who's a professor at brown
and he has a lot of really amazing work
in seminal work and
reinforcement learning especially
partial observability and a really
broad uh a
very large gamut of topics is published
on from
you know game favorite self-driving cars
to the psychology of learning to dq
learning
and i am excited to hear this talk which
i think is more closer to the similar
part of rl but please
take it away thanks very much
uh yeah i don't know if i can live up to
that i also was thinking
in the beginning akshay was saying that
it was kind of microsoft new york day
and i was going to be like yeah me too i
was at microsoft new york last summer so
i'm part of that crowd
and then i heard the talks from the
microsoft new york people and i thought
i don't want to bring down their average
so just
if if you like what i say you can credit
it to them but you know but
mostly you can just say that this is
this is me so
um uh yeah i kind of i kind of was
picturing this
the whole workshop is actually being a
lot of you know chatting and thinking
about philosophy and stuff but
but the talks have been amazing and uh
and highly technical and so this might
not be quite as technical as some of
them but um
i thought it was nice and it and and it
you know it connects with chubba so
that's always a positive thing so
uh this is an alternative softmax
operator for reinforcement learning
uh work primarily uh carried out by my
student cabos who actually defended his
dissertation yesterday during this
workshop so i had to
bug out uh to oversee that process
and he did great and uh he did this work
in a bunch of other projects
um also somewhat connected with
microsoft but he ended up at amazon of
all places
and so we'll see how that turns out in
the long run all right
so uh we've talked a little bit about
the the kind of the reinforcement
learning model
markov decision processes states actions
rewards transitions discount factors
etc uh the goal of a of an agent trying
to learn to maximize
its uh future expected discounted reward
and the fundamental quantities that we
tend to talk about are things like the
policy that maps states to actions the
value function
uh with respect to a policy which says
if i start in this state and follow the
policy what's my future expected
discounted reward going to be
the uh the action value function or the
q function
in this case with respect to a policy
which is the same thing except
uh possibly well i'm going to take a
specific action a
first before embarking on policy pi and
and of course the the transition
function so
um what i want to get at
is this notion that the um
let's see it's not on the slide which is
good all right so here
we have some notion of a policy so
what's the policy
uh what policy do you want to take you
could just be like i'm random
or you could be somehow guided by for
example the values that you've been
learning and representing
so uh the typical thing that we do for
for the bellman equation or for q
learning
is that we're going to say when i'm in a
state uh that has a set of actions so
looking
on the left-hand side of the screen
there there's four different actions
they have different values associated
with them
i'm going to put all my money on
whichever action has the highest value
so i'm going to take the
max and the current state of all the
actions i could take in that state
and that's that's what i'm committing to
and so my value should come from that
action
and my behavior should be that action
and this is
known as greedy action selection um you
know we're going to be taking that
optimal action we're not doing any kind
of exploration or anything like that
now of course if the q values that
you've got are not fully
learned yet taking that greedy action
that maximum value action isn't
necessarily a wise thing to do
you want to maybe mix it up a little bit
and so what we
have on the right hand side of the
screen which of course zoom isn't
showing me
but hopefully you can see is the notion
that we have a set of actions
with different values and we're going to
allocate our probability of taking an
action
in some way related to the values like
maybe we'll take
a3 which is the maximum action more with
higher probability
but we'll also take the other actions
with some probability as well so we can
find out more about how they work
so we're going to take more do more
exploration
we're going to take sub-optimal actions
or what we believe to be sub-optimal
actions some of the time
which means we're exploiting less
relative to our state of knowledge but
as we're learning over time we're going
to be improving our understanding the
environment and hopefully getting more
reward having a better
estimate of what those values actually
are
so all right so kabus drew a little
picture this is pac-man in a grid he's
got a
apple which is a good thing you want to
try to get to the apple and then he's
got a
covered virus uh in the middle which is
a bad thing you don't want to bump into
that
so keep your you know keep washing your
hands and don't have your mouth open so
wide
so uh the what we're what we're thinking
about here is the idea of
when we're in some state like state
seven and there's the set of actions
that we can take from state seven
how are we sort of aggregating those
values into a single value to say how
good it is to be in state seven
so we're mapping a vector over actions
to a single scalar
and the the q learning bellman equation
optimality sort of notion is we're going
to take uh
assign the value to be that maximum
value over all the actions
but you could also take the mean like if
i'm behaving randomly then my value for
being in that state is going to be the
average of
of the values of those actions or maybe
i could be epsilon greedy right so
epsilon greedy says that with
some uh large probability one minus
epsilon i'm going to take the maximum
action and we're going to get that
expected value
but with some small probability uh we're
going to take the
the the mean value over over all the
actions all right so those are these are
all sort of different ways that we can
summarize a set of values
one thing that people have noticed and
have used in practice is to say well i'd
really i don't
yeah it's good to put a lot of weight on
the maximum but like what about the
second
largest like that would be a good thing
to put some more probability of mass on
as well and this epsilon greedy approach
just says okay there's the
there's the max and then there's
everybody else
so the boltzmann weighting says what
we're going to do is we're going to take
the q values our our value estimates of
all the individual
actions we're going to multiply them by
beta and take e to that power and call
that a kind of a weight
we're going to get turn that weight into
a probability by normalizing it by the
sum
over all the actions and then we're
going to weight each q
value uh for for each of the different
actions that we consider taking
we're going to weight it by that
probability and in fact
we could behave according to that
probability as well so we're going to
more often take high valued actions and
less often take
lower valued actions and this parameter
beta
kind of lets us control how much we're
going to be acting randomly and just
exploring
and how much we're going to be
maximizing how much we're going to
amplify
the the probability that we put
on the highest value q value
so these are all things that people do i
guess mean is not really something that
people do when they build
uh like q learning algorithms but um but
the other ones you know epsilon greedy
is very popular you see it in current
papers boltzmann exploration
is very popular as well so
uh back in the day uh chubba and i
said well if we have all these different
ways of summarizing values
can we take the standard bellman
equation which is what's on the screen
now
and and modify it to reflect
these other ways of aggregating values
together so we can
replace the max with like a generalized
x with a circle around it a generalized
operator that
is meant to stand in here for some
method for summarizing a set of values
and we could if we do that then we can
have a kind of a generalized
value iteration algorithm or a
generalized q learning algorithm that
says we're going to update our values
not according to uh the reward plus
the discounted expected value of the
next state but
uh well it is still that but the value
of that next state is going to be taken
with respect to this operator
as opposed to just pure maximization so
we're going to include
lots of other sorts of things in this
sort in this one equation in this one
generalized algorithm
and what we showed in that older work is
that
as long as that summary operator as long
as that x with a circle around it
satisfies this kind of lipschitz
property uh
things are going to be okay so we call
it the non-expansion property
and the non-expansion property says that
when we summarize the values
between two different possible sets of
values right so we've got a set of
values another set of values
we're going to summarize each of those
sets of values and compare the result
we want it to be the case that that is
no larger
than the largest difference between
those two
sets of values at any position any given
action position
right so so uh there's the difference
between the first action
values the difference between the second
action values the third action values
the fourth action values
that needs to be an upper bound on the
the difference between the summaries of
those two
right if that holds if we have that
property for our x operator
then we can use it in the context of
value iteration and everything works
fine
so that uh so then now that leaves us
with a new problem which is
if we want to show that a
a particular way of defining values a
particular way of
choosing actions as it were by values
has this property then we get that
there's a unique unique fixed point we
can use generalized value iteration to
find it
we can get we get convergence in
something like q learning
so it's all good stuff but now we
actually have to prove that different
operators
have this property
so you know naturally this wouldn't be
super interesting if max didn't have
this property but it but it does
um that the value that we get
that is the difference between the max
values of two sets of values here i've
got
a set of blue values and a set of black
values is
upper bound or yeah it's bounded above
by the largest component-wise difference
of any of the
the given action so we have that
property that means we can put max in
there
we've known this everybody people have
known this since the 40s so that's
there's no big revelation
uh with respect to that but it's nice
that it kind of plugs in lego style to
this
this uh this more generalized algorithm
mean does as well
it's easy to show that the mean hold has
this property
um i think it's neat nobody seems to
find it useful but the median also has
this property which i think is very very
cool
so many statistics that start with
m can be used in the context of this
particular algorithm
midpoint is another one in fact the
convex combination of any of these
things of which
the midpoint is the is the average of
the max and the min
oh min also has this uh minimax also
starts with m
and also has this property uh in fact
that was the reason that we that we
tried to prove it in the first place is
that we were trying to show that
a certain kind of game theoretic version
of cue
learning would converge but once we had
it we had this sort of general
tool and lots of things could be used in
this context
and so i was interested in okay what
about the boltzmann operator well the
boltzmann operator turns out
not to have this property and at least
at the time of my dissertation
um that's all i knew i knew it didn't
have this property but i didn't know
that it wouldn't converge like i didn't
know whether or not it would converge
there are some algorithms
some operators we can plug in here that
converge in spite of the fact that they
don't satisfy this property
and i didn't know about boltzmann and i
said this in
my in my rl class a couple years ago and
coverage was one of the students in the
class and he's like
oh well you could use this other
operator and he wrote down an operator
i'm like that's interesting it turns out
to be pretty closely
related to some other things that people
have used in the past
but it's um it's boltzmann like so so
let me just kind of talk through this
equation we're taking the
q values we're weighting them by omega
here
very similar to the to the boltzmann
case we're taking e to that just like
the boltzmann case
we're summing that over all the action
just like the boltzmann case but
generally in the boltzmann case at this
point we would then weight that by the q
value
and then normalize but what we're going
to do instead is average it
one over number of actions uh
and then take the log of that value and
divide by omega
so it wasn't obvious to me that this was
even a sensible thing to do it might be
more mathy people might uh instantly see
oh yeah of course that's the
whatever pershmitty average or something
but um
but you know to me i'm like i don't even
think that makes any sense so we went
about trying to prove some properties of
it and it turned out that
um yeah it actually acts a lot like
boltzmann in a lot of ways
but it is but it has some some
significant differences so here's some
things that you can notice when you when
you play with this if uh
we've got a set of values one two three
four and we apply this
kavosh calls it mello max it's like a
mellow it's like max but it's more
mellow i don't know
he i told him that was a terrible name
but he really became very attached to it
so melamax
mellow has this parameter omega if we
summarize the values one two three four
as that value omega goes to infinity
what you get out in the case of one two
three four
is four as that value omega
goes to zero then we get the average of
one two three four which is two and a
half
and for values in between values of
omega in between we get this kind of
soft
interpolation between the mean on one
side and the
and the max on the other side and in
fact that that really holds in general
not just for one two three four
but any any vector values that we've got
as this parameter omega goes to infinity
it becomes the max operator and as this
omega gets cranked down to zero
it becomes mean and if you just keep
cranking it back and go to negative
infinity
it becomes min so it's sort of you know
everything you could possibly want it's
the swiss army knife of uh
of averagers
so uh this contraction so it has this
contract it has
ultimately the operator the bolts the uh
the bellman operator with respect to
this
this way of summarizing values has the
contraction property which means
as we apply that operator to values to
vectors values the summaries are getting
closer and closer to each other and that
means
that there is some value in the space
which in this case is marked by the red
rectangle
that everybody is going to go to any
value vector that we start with if we
keep applying this operation it's going
to get closer and closer and closer it's
going to converge to
that fixed point so um
so the properties that we have of this
this melomax operator is that it is a
non-expansion
unlike the the boltzmann case the
boltzmann
averager uh we have this non-expansion
property it acts like boltzmann but it's
actually sort of friendlier it's
unlike the epsilon greedy it's
differentiable like i said the
in the limit as you play with this beta
parameter it can be max min
or mean you can extract
the policy from it right so even though
it's just a way of summarizing values
you can use that to assign probabilities
to the actions that would achieve that
value
the the maximum entries entropy such
policy
has the boltzmann form which is neat but
you don't get to pick the boltzmann
parameter it's going to pick that
parameter
so that it has the the you know this
property so that
summarizes to this particular value
all right and so we can plug it into
generalized value iteration and we get
an algorithm
and so we've been playing with this
algorithm i should probably be keeping
track of time that would be smart
but of course i can give you a five
minute warning if that helped
all right where are we in time right now
you have 13 minutes left okay thanks i
should get more computer screens i think
that would be a
beneficial thing or just a clock a clock
would be good all right so here's uh
here's a particular mdp a really simple
mdp
uh basically one state two actions
action
uh a0 action a1 if you take action a0
you get a reward of 0.12 and with
two-thirds probability essentially it
goes back to s0 and with one-third
probability it advances to a terminal
state with no more reward
action a1 has a much smaller reward just
.03
but a 99 probability of bringing you
back to where you started
all right so right so more chances to
get value but kind of less value so this
is a really simple mdp and what's what's
nice about the
simplicity the the smallness of it is
that it's really the the q values are
really
just or the q function is just two
numbers and so we can represent it as a
as a value in the plane
so we can ask the question of given a
starting q function which again is just
a point like how much
uh what's the q value for action a zero
what's the q value for action a1
we can plot that on a graph and say if
we apply
the bellman update with this particular
summary operator being
well in one case boltzmann in the other
case melomax
um where does it move the value function
to right it's
this the bellman operator is a is a it's
a mapping on value function so it's
going to take our
our point and it's going to move it to
another point in the space
when we when we apply uh a boltzmann
operator with some particular value of
beta setting to it
the value functions kind of move around
in a
and what turns out to be a very awkward
way so there's this dividing line marked
in gray here
where everything to the left of that
dividing line
the the value functions will move
eventually to a fixed point
but everything to the to the right of
that gray line it will also move to a
fixed point but it's a different fixed
point
so we don't get a unique solution to the
bellman equation in this case and partly
for that reason
it it it tends to converge really really
slowly so it just
it just acts awkwardly it acts badly
uh melomax on the other hand we can pick
some value of its parameter
and we get this sort of nice vector
field that's all going to
uh to a fixed point so single fixed
point and it gets there relatively
rapidly in fact we can actually do that
calculation we can say for
for each of the possible settings of the
beta parameter in the boltzmann
uh the boltzmann using the boltzmann
operator
how many iterations does this take
before it actually converges to a fixed
point and for
really small values of beta it's
actually quite fast the black line on
the graph here is
what you'd get if you just applied the
standard value iteration operation
value iteration uh solution to it which
is going to iterate
with the max operator and see how long
it takes to converge
to within some epsilon of of the fixed
point
that's that's the black line the blue
line is saying it actually converges
even faster than
the max operator for small values of
beta and maybe
a little bit for big values of beta but
there's an in-between value of beta
where it starts to actually explode and
and convergence just takes a really
really long time the values are just
barely moving at all sort of undecided
as to which fixed point it's going to go
to
whereas the melomax operator regardless
of how we set the omega parameter we're
always getting something that
is uh it's always converging it's always
converging relatively quickly
it's pretty close to what we get in the
in the max case
that's on that particular mdp that i
just showed you if i generate
random mdps and i ask how long does it
take for
value iteration to converge uh we find
for the boltzmann operator
our you know eight of the 200 random
mdps
it didn't terminate it just it just ran
until we ran until we got bored of
running it
um and in three of those cases it
actually identified multiple different
fixed points
um the average iterations was larger
than what we got from lmax
which never failed to terminate and
never found more than one fixed point
because
we proved that in fact that that's the
case um
and the experiments back that up uh so
what we're seeing here is an operator
that
is acting a lot like boltzmann except
for in this very important way that it's
much more stable it's much more reliable
you can use it in
in a productive way i think i had some
more graphs on the side there which i
can't see
so i'm not going to talk about them but
i think i think they come from
what do they say
i can get i'll pop out for a second and
look uh
mean return max entropy mellow epsilon
greedy
yeah we ran on some other mdp some i
think it was um lunar lander or
something like that and and we got uh
slightly better performance from melomax
when we set the
the omega parameter just so but we got
very good performance over
a wide range of values actually both for
boltzmann and for max entropy but not so
much for epsilon greedy which is kind of
a terrible way of
doing exploration even though people
seem to do it all the time
people there's uh yeah sorry there was
one question
and the question is if the fixed points
from mello max
relate to the fixed point from boltzmann
in some way
in characterizable way uh well
yes it's going to be the so okay first
of all boltzmann
we don't know that it has a fixed point
i guess
it could orbit potentially i don't think
we've ever seen that case i wouldn't
it probably always has at least one
fixed point but sometimes it has two
so that those two may relate to the
melomax thing
the thing is that they have very
different parameters boltzmann has this
beta parameter
melomax has an omega parameter the fixed
point that we get from
melomax is always derivable
by finding the appropriate value of beta
for boltzmann and then it becomes the
fixed point of that
operator so we always get um
the melomax for every value of omega
creates a boltzmann with some value of
beta
that um that is going to be well behaved
because boltzmann's not always terrible
it's just and you can see it on the on
this graph on this slide too
it's just that there's there's this sort
of scary range and you don't know a
priori whether or not you're in it
and uh melomax sort of interestingly
like keeps you out of that zone it ends
up picking a
boltzmann value for beta that's that's
not in that bad space
so since this was acting very nicely on
the little tiny mdps that we were
playing with we decided
you know everything's deep these days so
we'll try uh deep q learning with
with this melomax operator in particular
to try to understand
the role of this this summary operator
this this would normally be max and how
it interacts
with a really important part of the deep
q learning algorithm
which is called the target network so
when you're
when you implement deep q learning what
you discover is that if you have just
one representation of your q function
and then do updates on it as you're
actually learning from the environment
you can get into these bad sort of
catastrophic forgetting situations where
the update that you make with the
current data point
actually causes it to unlearn something
that it knew before and then when you
update with another data point
it things start to fall apart keep
updating and then you get
you know it just things things
completely don't work at all so one of
the
uh one of the great insights that the
the
i guess now deepmind team though i think
they they were pre-deep mind when they
had it
no they were deep mind but they were not
google deep mind um was this notion of
well here's what we're going to do to
stabilize
the use of function approximation in
model-free reinforcement learning we're
going to
freeze a representation of the value
function and then do a bunch of updates
with respect to that frozen
value function until we're pretty
confident that we have stable values
across enough of the state space
then we do a step of learning and update
the the value function that way so that
that frozen network is the is the target
network
and it's really awkward to have that
because now you've got basically two
copies of the value function that you're
training
kind of simultaneously and it's it
complicates the algorithm it makes it
more expensive to run so it'd be great
if you could get rid of that
and so we said well okay maybe we can
get rid of it by actually replacing the
max
in q learning with melomax because maybe
part of the problem here
is that the max operator is actually
accentuating some bad
estimated values and causing things to
spiral out of control so if we just
you know ask it to be a little more
mellow you know smooth it out a little
bit
then maybe we've taken away that um that
positive feedback loop that's that's
killing us
and in fact that's that's basically what
we found at least in a bunch of the uh
like atari testbed games that that
people have been using for testing these
algorithms
that uh the the red line here
generalized dqn with the melomax
operator
was actually getting higher return sort
of better learning curves across a set
of games including
uh this the submarine game and the this
pongish kind of game breakout
um that was doing better than dqn with
the target network and
much better certainly in the case of the
of the submarine game
than dqm if we took the target network
away so it really is this
that the dqn with no target network and
that's the purplish or bluish line
and generalized dqn with melomax are the
same algorithm
except we're just we just took the max
out and we're using
the the melomax operator instead and we
get this huge increase in stability
which results in much higher
return in the environment
after we published this work another
group took took a really close look at
what the melomax operator was doing and
the connection to
the boltzmann operator and maximum
entropy perspective
and they showed that another way of
thinking about this
is what we're doing is finding the
policy
that is regularized with it's
it's an entropy regularized version of
the of the greedy policy
so it's it's trying to uh essentially
maximize
the the value while at the same time
including an entropy term
and so we get this uh you know what
we're trying to do is maximize
the sum of the expected value of the of
the q's find the policy that maximizes
that
subject to this constraint this this
extra bit of regularization
that says well you can't also like don't
be too maxi right don't be too s
spiky as a distribution try to be more
mellow than that
what they showed is that in fact it's
doing the same thing that the melomax
operator by summarizing the values in
that way
it's solving this this uh this
particular problem
of uh entropy regularizing the
the max operator so i thought that was
sort of cute and worth mentioning
all right so that was that was the whole
story that i wanted to talk about that
uh
this melomax provides an alternative to
boltzmann exploration or epsilon greedy
with better convergent guarantees rich
value-dependent exploration like
boltzmann has
um and just sort of some useful
smoothness properties that
that seem to make things conditionally
are
much more stable in general
thanks
thank you really great talking um i
think there was one question
um from uh raunchy actually now there
too but
i'll just read the first one uh raunchy
asks if the mapping from
melmax boltzmann is unique given that
the voltmeters have multiple optima
and uh lmx does not
if the mapping so so when we when we
want to find
all right so so the way that we get
boltzmann from melomax is we say okay
melomax summarizes
we give it a vector of numbers and it
summarizes those and gets a particular
value
there is a non-unique mapping of uh
probabilities to those values that co
that such that the expected value with
respect to those probabilities will give
us that value
but what we're saying is take of all
those distributions that you could
possibly be
interested in take the one that
maximizes the entropy
if you do that then you get the value
you're still getting that value out that
target value out like you're supposed to
but of all the distributions that have
that property we're taking the maximum
entropy one
that has the boltzmann form is there a
unique
boltzmann form for each of those in most
cases yes but i don't
i guess i don't know if it's if it's
across the board it could be
like like if all the values were zero
it's it's
definitely the case that we should get
which there should be multiple values of
beta that would produce that same
answer so it's probably not unique but i
don't know if there's
something stronger to say than that okay
interesting
and i guess one more quick question from
the chats uh
from julia who asks why the why using a
higher temperature for the boltzmann
doesn't solve the spikiness problem of
the boltzmann operator
well if you use a high enough beta with
the boltzmann it becomes like maximizing
and then everything is cool
yeah that's true you kind of lose the
benefit of using boltzmann you might as
well just use max
so i think you know our hope is that you
get you're trying to get both right
you're trying to get something that's
well behaved and relatively stable
but also spreads the wealth a little bit
so that we get some reasonable
exploration
all right um higher temperature means
lower beta
oh okay sorry sorry uh well sure i mean
that works too
you can always make it very stable by by
going the other direction and turning it
into mean
because then you're basically saying i'm
estimating the value of an
agent that is just blind and random and
that is extremely stable
but is not very i don't know
aggressively optimizing
right that makes sense great
well i guess we'll maybe have more
questions with discussion but
let's thank michael again great talk